ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
cucina buttata oggi faremo una ricetta
riprendendo in mano due dei nostri
cavalli di battaglia le pizzette che in
passato sono andate molto bene e il
microonde che non tocchiamo ormai da
troppo troppo tempo si è d'accordo il
ricordo ecologisti fare un pò schifo ma
non serviva questo come un motivo detto
ciò abbiamo preso ispirazione dal video
di daniele minelli con il quale faceva
una intera pizza margherita all'interno
del microonde trattamente se con ottima
anche la pa citato io posso solamente
che andare peggio e non riguardavano
sempre se ce li ascolta ci è riuscita
anche voi oggi scopriremo se è possibile
fare velocemente delle pizzette
all'interno del forno a microonde per
far il pizzetto a microonde del perfetto
latitante culinario avremmo bisogno di
un tot di farina un tot di acqua un tot
di oggi un tot di lievito un tot di
passata un tot di mozzarella per pizza
un tot di basilisco è un tot di sale per
fare queste pizzette ho deciso di non
darvi dosi perché perché facciamo occhio
facile che tu prendi sbarchi tempo
all'acquedotto il lievito fine non
abbiamo tempo se ne facciamo al
microonde di sicuro non è che abbiamo
voglia di stare lì a fare i nostri
panificatori no quindi farina un tot
questo sarà il mio tutto secondo però
due ebrei preso la farina da una pur
piccola e l'ha visto il più grande mi
spieghi nella bull piccola c'è il vino
buono acqua a occhio così e guarda scusa
mai visto farina acqua
ti senti uno chef con questa mossa
ricoh sono inutile brava un po di olio
sul metodo se non tutti mettono l'olio
io sia qui fine del suo discorso bidet
del grande discorso che voleva aprire
anche qui ma è pochissimo tutta la
bustina ma non si muoveva pensavo
fossero sono presenti granelli
quell'anno a z no no no è bianco dei
grandi linee più scuri io non vedevo il
bianco vedo sosti 4 granellini sfigate
bomba che ha detto rancia dell'aitante
se già inizio si mette i guanti
l'impasto vorresti vedere superpotere di
vedere il phon il futuro di poco di poco
sini però dovreste avere il potere di
poter vedere lontanissimo è comunque non
riesco a vedere il fondo delle tue
battute con le mani sbucci le cipolle
che è che la canta tu che è tipo
perfetta è un po canosa e rafa è che
perché perché devi passare olio di
gomiti superi è l'unico olio che vedrà
vi era fermo bella questa bella
platonica battuta annuale l'abbiamo
tolta a febbraio il resto dei dieci mesi
calore delle mani e vero c'è bisogno del
calore braque cosa hai fatto aggiunge la
piega spiega e c'è bisogno del calore
delle mani perché
comunque l'impasto va maltrattato tu lo
sai accarezzando questo qua bello
giuseppe vivere libero meccanica bravo
una volta aver creato una palletta
[Musica]
pizzico di culo
immagino tu debba gorilla gravissimo che
mina che siamo una camera a vedere
quanto diventa bellissimo ti piace
mezz'ora riuniamo cucina buttata a
scienza
dove di doppio la boutique al portello
ma dobbiamo andiamo a finire ed
infarinare il nostro nome è neanche
aspettato per infarinare il piano ah beh
perché affettiamo intera proprio la
scena che avrebbe commosso e persone
puoi vedere un'altra cosa che ho fatto
mentre nocerino già messo questo foglio
soprattutto al vassoio tale affare
grande cinema al grande cinema è vero
c'è ragione mai avresti fatto che quindi
melo sarebbe stata
non l'abbiamo fatto sta cazzata sette
green e farina sul piano prendiamo il
nostro cargo lo deve il nome pargolo
fatto sapere i commenti non potrebbe io
lo chiamerei pari del parco ragazzi
stendiamo spendiamo stendiamo stendiamo
sottili hack un carro armato i miei
[ __ ] che girano vanno così veloci
che sembrano 200 la cosa migliore adesso
sarebbe farli riposare ancora un raga
diventano morbidissime facciamo vengono
ancora più buona e invece dalla visita
dei magli tortino non parli perché non
sa incazzo presa questa con la mossa non
ti aspettare da nel modello strapazzi
caviglia e quindi vi rimanessi
direttamente il cerchio mia po deluso
guardate una cosa non ho ancora visto
come ripreso questo video ma sono sicuro
che meno il sentimento sarà reciproco
non è che l'ho tagliato con la spada di
attori ha leso aspetti un 20 minuti
altri 20 minuti
nel farlo perfetto da futuro se non
viene effetto 60 ha detto mamma quando
ha fatto il quarto figlio
alla fine abbiamo aspettato un mezz'ora
mette in mezzo ma perché ci vogliamo
rovinare vediamo che cosa è successo non
è qualcosina piccole schiavi
ok dai libertiamo direttamente sulla
teglia enrico tutti rende conto che il
cosmo ha voluto questo sono finiti c'è
chi è finito lo spazio non ha messo il
sale dell'impasto lo metto sopra
adesso è la prova del nove dobbiamo
mettere nel forno a micronde metto anche
un po di acqua in forno a microonde
sapete perché perché così in forno
microonde lo in secca o alcune persone
invece prendo una piccola sorellina e ce
la mettono tipo in un lauto del vassoio
tre minuti e mezzo andiamo a tagliare la
mozzarella nel frattempo io sono pieno
di corbis in cucina ma guarda quante più
facile
ha detto che uno scempio se qualcuno
dice che lo fa anche lui qualcuno
aggiunge il manager parte di una vita
serena contrattacca questa roba
prendiamo anche il basilisco sempre con
le mete fidatissime favore decente
geniale chiamarlo basilisco lo riconosco
il grande riconoscimento ottico dolore
enrico stanno venendo tv di come stanno
venendo ora sono leggermente crude
dovremo sciogliere la mozzarella mentre
cuocerle andiamo con un dio spider man
queste non solo pizzette al microonde
sono pizzetti all'occhio guarda il mio
occhio a cazzo di cane di gould ieri con
minuscole sono infatti è ovunque la
mozzarella per tre minuti senza l'acqua
per starle mammamia speriamo bene enrico
letta spetta google google temo che
siamo andati bene adesso ma c'è un
grande ma questo ragazzo avere una volta
bellissime lo so
marco siamo tutti sconvolti quanto tempo
un genio sul dischetto si fa in merito
al basilico tritato mentre gianmarco
[ __ ] cucchiaino cucchiaini
cucchiaino e mele oggettino d'olio a
crudo su twitter è che cadine siamo
arrivati al momento dell'assaggio spero
che siano cotte dure o secche le
asciugate dentro per me comunque
rimangono serali e dalle capito che per
niente di buono
e la prima volta che dopo l'impatto del
genere dove però la base era perfetta
messa nel forno scusi se non ha senso
mettere le microonde xvi in realtà la
puoi mettere in forno dieci minuti
ragazzi in questa guerra non è nostra e
pizzette a microonde e spero che vi
piacciono se li farete tac ha deciso di
instagram nel frattempo iscrivetevi al
canale
ma tra kampala notifica altrimenti delle
erbe
siamo giovani alle 14 con un altro video
ciao baci ti voglio bene